oh yeah things did get heated in a
pre-game
it was it was really nothing though it
was just talking
yeah that's what most teams gonna do a
lot of teams just want to talk
coaches talking
I don't get why the coaches talking but
come on man this coach is in 18 talking
man I don't really do nothing but just
because God never performed
I was supposed to perform I'm happy we
came away with the lane even though I
wasn't able to come back but yeah we did
what we're supposed to do
a little stuff let's go for just a
little argument in the middle of the
field
[Music]
just talking man we're just talking back
to him so that's why that was that's all
that's going on right here
I like the city appreciate it man